effectivement une seconde victoire du
club franciscain dans ce trophée des
champions de la caf ce vraiment une
consécration pour le club pour ses
joueurs qui font tant de sacrifices
c'est vrai que avec cette victoire le
club est qu à une nouvelle page du
football martiniquais
maintenant à nous de rester bien
concentré déterminé pour pouvoir
l'emporter et pourquoi pas vivre encore
une épopée comme l'an dernier en
jamaïque avec cette victoire
cela nous permet d'avoir une ouverture
sous la caraïbe de faire rayonner le
football martiniquais
quand il y est j'espère vraiment qu'on
pourra avec l'ensemble du groupe
atteignent cet objectif